j'avais une vie normale triste sans
piment
on se demandait si tu étais pas
différent différents professionnellement
j'étais le larbin de quatre auteurs à
succès la chance je l'attendais heureux
je ne l'étais pas et doit j'ai créé mon
studio et à la map en est cette gamme de
papiers peints j'avais envie et besoin
que quelque chose change dans mci et
puis un jour à l'eau non non non c'est
une erreur
je n'arrivais pas à y croire je n'avais
qu'à écrire pour sa rue
le stylo allait m'apporter l'existence
cueillir pour exister le premier roman
est déjà best-seller de l'écrivain max
taille aux que nous recevons ce soir
j'appelle le pouvoir à tous
vraiment il reste c'est pas moi c'est le
stylo ribes skeate comment tu crois que
tu devenu riche et célèbre de mes potes
rend pas compte de la chance que tu as
et ses potes et moi ta vie donc c'est
bon de finir
[Musique]